.
TREY: JOINING US NOW SENATE
MINORITY WHIP FROM SOUTH
DAKOTA SENATOR JOHN THUNE,
HISTORY ON G.O.P. SIDE, THE
ECONOMY IS NOT DOING WELL,
YET THE PROJECTIONS ARE
ACCORDING TO SOME FOR
DEMOCRATS TO HOLD THE
SENATE, DO
BELIEVE THAT TO BE TRUE?
IF SO, WHY?
>> I DON'T, TREY, I THINK
WE'LL WIN IT.
BY THE WAY NICE TO BE WITH
YOU, AND CONGRATULATIONS ON
THE SHOW.
I JUST THINK THAT IN THE
END, WHEN PEOPLE
FUNDAMENTALS OF THIS
ELECTION YEAR LOCK IN AND
PEOPLE LOOK AT THESE
CANDIDATES, THE ISSUES WILL
BE CLEAR, THE CONTRAST WILL
BE CLEAR, THE DEMOCRATS ARE
TRYING TO WAVE SHINY OBJECTS
AND MAKE IT ABOUT SOMETHING
ELSE.
IN THE END IT IS ABOUT PRICE
OF FOOD, GASOLINE AND OUR
ENERGY SECURITY AND THE
BORDER, AND WHAT A DISASTER
THAT.
IS AND IT WILL BE PEOPLE
ANSWERING THE QUESTION, DO I
FEEL SAFE IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD.
IN MY COMMUNITY AND COUNTRY?
THERE IS A SECURITY ISSUE.
ECONOMIC SECURITY, ENERGY
SECURITY.
NATIONAL SECURITY, I THINK
THOSE ARE ISSUES THAT WILL
MOTIVATE VOTERS ON ELECTION
DAY, I THINK THAT THE
CONVENTIONAL WISDOM, THE YOU
KNOW THOSE WHO PONTIFICATE
ABOUT THESE ELECTIONS RIGHT
NOW SUGGEST PERHAPS THAT
DEMOCRATS HAVE AN EDGE IN
SENATE BUT I DON'T THINK
THAT WILL PLAY OUT THAT WAY,
I THINK IN THE END IT WILL
BE ARE YOU SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS CRAZY AGENDA THAT HAS
GIVEN YOU 40 YEAR HIGH
INFLATION, AND YOU KNOW,
JUST A WIDE OPEN POROUS
BORDER CREATING ALL KIND OF
SECURITY ISSUES AND CRIME IN
THE CITIES, THESE ARE WHAT
MOTIVATE PEOPLE TO VOTE.
TREY: SENATOR, WHEN I
REFLECT BACK ON BEING AROUND
YOU, REASONABLE LEVEL-HEADED
MATURE ADULT, YOU ARE THE
PERFECT PERSON FOR ME TO ASK
ABOUT REASONABLE
EXPECTATIONS.
EVEN IF THE HOUSE AND SENATE
WERE TO FLIP TO G.O.P.,
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS STILL IN
OFFICE UNTIL JANUARY OF
2025.
WHAT IS A REALISTIC
EXPECTATION FOR REPUBLICAN
VOTERS GIVEN THE FACT
THAT DEMOCRAT WILL BE IN
WHITE HOUSE EVEN IF
REPUBLICANS TAKES HOUSE AND
SENATE.
>> GOOD POINT.
AND YOU ARE GETTING AN ISSUE
THAT PEOPLE WILL BE THINKING
OUT IN TERMS OF WHAT CAN A
CONGRESS
ACCOMPLISH WITH A DEMOCRAT
IN THE WHITE HOUSE WITH A
VETO PEN, THIS WILL FORCE
PEOPLE TO PRIORTIZE.
PRIORTIZE.
>> WE BE IN A BETTER
POSITION TO FORCE HIM TO THE
TABLE, MAYBE FORCES BIDEN TO
BECOME THE MODERATE HE
PROMISED HIGH WOULD BE IN
THE FIRST PLACE, IT REMAINS
TO BE SEEN, ONE THING I KNOW
THIS COUNTRY AND AMERICAN
PEOPLE NEED A CHECK AND
BALANCE AGAINST A RECKLESS
EXTREME FAR LEFT AGENDA,
WHICH HAS BEEN PROMOTED BY
THIS ADMINISTRATION AND
THEIR
LEADERSHIP?
CONGRESS, NO QUESTION IF MY
MIND PEOPLE WILL LOOK FOR
SOMETHING THAT SAYS WE WANT
TO GO IN A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION.
THEY GET THE HOUSE AND
SENATE BACK.
AND I THINK MORE THAN
ANYTHING ELSE WE HAVE TO
STOP THE BLEEDING AND STOP
MADNESS AND CRAZY SPENDING
AND THE YOU KNOW IN BELIEF
THAT WE DON'T NEED ALL OF
THE ABOVE AMERICAN ENERGY
PROGRAM.
THAT MAKES US ENERGY
INDEPENDENT AND FOCUSED ON
GIVING YOU KNOW WEALTHY
PEOPLE TAX CREDITS FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLES THAT THE
SUM TOTAL OF THEIR ENERGY
PROGRAM, THAT I THINK THAT
ADMINISTRATION AND PEOPLE OF
LOOK FOR A CHANGE FROM THIS
ADMINISTRATION'SGENDA.
TREY: WE HAVE GOT A LITTLE
BIT OF TIME LEFT.
I AM VACCINATED AS PEOPLE
WRESTLE WITH WITH WHETHER OR
NOT TO STAY IN PUBLIC
SERVICE, I THINK YOU REALLY
WRESTLED IN ANY TO STAY IN
WHAT HAS PROVEN TO BE A SAVE
SEAT FOR YOU, DID YOU
WRESTLE WHETHER OR NOT TO
RUN FOR REELECTION AND WHY
DO YOU DO IT.
>> YOU KNOW, I DID IT.
WE MISS YOU IN CONGRESS.
WE NEED I THINK REALLY
PRINCIPLED LEADERS PEOPLE
WHO ARE WILLING TO ICE
USE COMMON SENSE TO
MAKE GOOD DECISIONS, I SAID
I FEEL THAT I HAVE SOMETHING
TO OFFER RIGHT NOW WHERE OUR
COUNTRY IS AND WORLD IS A
TIME WE NEED PEOPLE WHO ARE
WILLING TO STEP IN TO THE
ARENA AND TO THE RIGHT THING
NO MATTER OF CONSEQUENCES OR
CIRCUMSTANCES.
IT WAS HARD, I GOT YOU KNOW
SPEND 35 TO 40 WEEKS' YEAR
IN DC, I HAVE A FAMILY AND
THE KIDS AND GRAND KIDS HERE
IN SOUTH CAROLINA.
AND -- SOUTH DAKOTA I WOULD
LOVE TO SPEND MORE TIME WITH
THEM, BUT IN THE END ' IT IS
ABOUT WANTING TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE, HOPEFULLY WE
WANT TO DO THINGS THAT
PURPOSE DRIVEN THAT SERVE
CAUSES GREATER THAN
OURSELVES.
AS YOU POINT OUT.
IT IS A PLACE WHERE IT CAN
GET FRUSTRATING, I
UNDERSTAND THE FRUSTRATION
THAT AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE
TOO AS THEY LOOK AT
WASHINGTON.
IT IS ABOUT TRYING TO GET
RESULTS AND SOLUTIONS AND
MAKING A DIFFERENCE.
TREY: THE PEOPLE OF SOUTH
DAKOTA' YOU BACK.
YOU WON YOUR PRIMARY
OVERWHELMINGLY, SENATOR JOHN